impfungen gegen das virus hiv gibt es
noch nicht aber mehr als 20 wirkstoffe
die hiv eine entstehung oder vermehrung
im körper hindern und ansteckungen
vermeiden
bisher sind insgesamt drei methoden
bekannt die gängigste kondome femidom
sie schützen beim sex nicht nur vor hiv
sondern auch vor anderen krankheiten
eine gezielte vorsorge gegen den
gefährlichen erreger bietet das
medikament trap mit seinen zwei
wirkstoffen verhindert prep dass sich
hiv im körper festsetzen und vermehren
kann
die tabletten werden täglich zu einer
bestimmten uhrzeit eingenommen
für männer ist nach zwei tagen der
schutz aufgebaut bei frauen nach sieben
tagen
trap tabletten sind nur für menschen die
den virus noch nicht im körper haben
das präparat dürfen nur spezialisierte
ärzte verschreiben
wer prep nimmt muss alle drei monate zur
untersuchung der in die tabletten können
unter anderem die nieren schädigen
laut einer studie soll bis 2030 rund
21.000 neue hiv infektionen in
deutschland verhindern
seit september übernehmen die
gesetzlichen krankenkassen die kosten
die privaten in hand haben das
unterschiedlich wer hiv positiv ist
sollte mit einer gezielten hiv-therapie
direkt anfangen die medikamente
unterdrücken die vermehrung des virus im
körper
meistens sind ein bis zwei tabletten am
tag notwendig ein leben lang die heilung
ist bislang nicht möglich
wer sich daran hält ist im alltag nicht
ansteckend auch nicht beim sex ohne
kondom
ohne behandlung schwächt hiv das
ein system und führt zu schweren
erkrankungen erst dann spricht man von
aids im schlimmsten fall kann das
tödlich enden